من باريس ينضم الينا هوراسل صباح العربيه
لايف فزاري ليث يسعد صباحك اهلا بك اشهر
شوارع العالم بلا سيارات وانا ونادين بدنا
نكون معك زين عيشتك اليوم تمام
الشعب السعودي بالفوز على الارجنتين يعني
المنتخب الاخضر اسعده واسعد العرب في
مونديال قطر والزميل محمد القناص في
النشره الرياضيه قدم ارقى وصف للنجاح في
بدايه نشرته عندما قال اذا اردت ان تكتب
التاريخ فاقت السعوديه قلبا الف مبروك
للسعوديه والعرب اذا رجعنا موضوع
الشانطيلي ازاي يرجع تاريخ شارع الشونسي
شو رايكم ناخذ الصوره مع الزميل صبحي
ونشوف في عمق الصوره يتحدث
عام 1616 حين شيدت الملكه ميسي طريق
محذوفا بالاشجار بهدف تامين التنزه للناس
وهو طبعا وهم كانوا داخل عربات الخيل انا
ذات اشرف على اعاده تشجيره الخبير في
الحدائق الملكيه عام 1967.67
حيث تضاعف من عدد اشجار هي اشجار هذه
الجاده على صفين منتظمين ومتواصلين من كل
جهه اتخذ اسم الشانزليزيه عام 1709 ومع
ذلك بقي هذا طيله القرن الثامن عشر شارعا
يؤمه الناس بالعربات في النهار ويتحول في
الليل الى مكان موحش ومخيف لا يتجرا
الكثير على المرور فيه ولم يكن فيه سوى
بعض المباني التي تعد على الاصابع همم او
اصابع اليد واحده انا ذاك اليوم لم يبقى
من هذه المباني القديمه سوى مبدا واحد يقع
رقم 25 من جده
تملكه
اصلا البرتغاليه وحين بنى الامبراطور
نابوليون بونابر قوس النصر تغريدا
لانتصاراته العسكريه ومعركه الحربيه اخذ
شارع الشانزليزيه اهميه وطنيه اكبر باعت
ان الجيوش الفرنسيه كانت تعبرها في طريق
الذهاب والعوده من الحروب يعني اذا حكينا
في القرن العشرين قررت فرنسا وضع النصب
التذكاري للجندي المجهول عند اعتاب قوس
النصر في جده الذي يزيد ارتفاعه على
الخمسين مترا تفضل سهام طيب ليس انا بس
بدي اسالك انه يعني الناس العايشين بره
فرنسا بتسال هذه منطقه سياحيه بامتياز
الناس تقصدها من كفت بقاع الارض يعني
بالسكان لماذا هذا القرار
بس ما عاد اخر سؤالك سهام عفوا نادين
بحركه المرور والناس لماذا هذا القرار من
قبل سلطات الفرنسيه يوم واحد بلا سيارات
نعم هذا القرار حتى طبعا بنعرف كثير انه
في مش بس الشانزليزيه في كثير شوارع في
باريس شوارع رئيسيه تحولت الى ممشا او بث
للمشا او للدراجات الهوائيه وهذا القرار
طبعا جاء من قبل رئيس بلديه باريس
اليدانجو عندما قررت ان تحول معظم الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه الى هذا الى هذا
الامر ان يكون ممشى وفي القرن التاسع عشر
تحولت جهادت الشانطيليزيه الى ما يشبه قلب
باريس النابض بالحياه خصوصا بعد ان تم
انارتها عام 1870 باكثر من 3000 ضوء تعمل
بالغاز ويبتدي الشانزلي بالطول مثل ما
شايفين خلفي همم اثنين كيلو متر ويعبر
من 100,000 سياره لتنتهي عند ساحه
الكونكورد ويبلغ عدد زوار الشنطه 220
مليون سائح سنويا واليوم اصبح هذا الشارع
طبعا من اهم الشوارع عقاريه اذا حكينا
اغتصاب فهي ثاني اغلى منطقه عقاريه في
العالم بعدما كانت في عام 1994 في المرتبه
العاشره عالميا همم ويعني طبعا هذا الشيء
بلا سيارات تتمشى معك في جده شكرا
لك